previously on TV since
[Music]
[Music]
another two minutes of opening credits I
promise this hurts me as much as it
hurts you but actions have consequences
this is what happens when a designer is
indecisive we have 30 tile patterns to
choose from which do you prefer oh is it
a bad thing for the mother of dragons
that she can't even play a simple game
of eeny meeny miny moe how do I know you
are who you say you are this is a great
question and it's about damn time
someone didn't know someone else in the
Seven Kingdoms there are way too many
scenes in this series of people
recognizing each other because of the
most mundane bullsh it's not Shane
McNulty Wow out of nine oh but he's got
a freckle so I should welcome you into
my service because you murdered members
of your own family Daenerys Stormborn of
House Targaryen first of her name queen
of the Andals and the first men
protector of the Seven Kingdoms the
mother of dragons the Khaleesi of the
great grass sea the unburnt and the
breaker of chains would be excellent a
TV since killing and politics aren't
always the same thing that's what I
thought when this goddamn show started
now look at me like at the sheiks
anytime there's any political meeting of
any kind Parks and Rec broke me out in
hives yesterday he's in love with you I
think aim of friends owns a ruler who
kills those devoted to her is not a
ruler who inspires devotion holy Dragon
Balls this whole scene rules but does it
make sense since when is Daenerys apt to
invite instruction from someone she just
met especially as stubborn as she is
about her own authority the show had
some very interesting things it wanted
to do here but it had to pull a bit of
character cheap to do it well now seems
like a good time to check in on my
contagious disease in front of possible
witnesses and at the moment of my
depressing exile just so the audience
can really feel it
also if Jorah has greyscale and it's as
infectious as the show says it is
he has just infected quite a few people
under Daenerys his rule right then
they'll touch people who will touch
other people so he's just destroyed
Daenerys his chances of ruling the Seven
Kingdoms I'm sure the show will follow
through with this logical path and not
just throw it aside and forget about it
it's about damn time I've had that
seriously gets hit with a wooden spoon
Blanc on my Game of Thrones bingo card
since the first season how is she seven
she will no longer turn left and
Ragman Lane she will turn right and go
to Ragman Harbor while I enjoy a good
Google Maps Westeros discussion as much
as the next throne II every time the
show cuts to this Aria storyline it
causes me to have a game of groans
seriously between this and the sparrows
I'm shocked the show didn't lose half
its audience in the fifth season she was
seen he walked apparently she will see a
hammock made for a giant with no
practical purpose to anyone during the
day as it provides no shade I'm not
accustomed to the blue water canal way
of things but couldn't one errant wave
spoil all the fruit I was wrong the
water just dropped five feet in an
instant and not one piece of produce is
capsized he said you didn't know what
I'd see at the docks a man had no idea
what a guy would see and what you would
not Arya stumbled upon an injustice that
seems worthy of a many-faced
assassination uh what if she had just
misinterpreted what she saw are we just
okay with killing anyone all right this
is Game of Thrones a gift foot a thin
man man if Nick Charles showed up right
now with a martini in his hand and a
broadsword and the other this would be
the greatest show ever
but he didn't she's not ready is anyone
ever ready to brutally murder a person
asking for a friend
fornication treason insists the murder
of king Roland script accidentally
includes the exact pitch for the show
also I get that Cersei thinks she's
above everyone but I still can't figure
out how she thought letting the sparrows
serve their own brand of justice
wouldn't bite her in the ass eventually
he wants to doom and call to his chaps
into the cross go to my piece after
piece so there was no Dion left and now
we've come to the traditional castration
conversation in the episode I deserved
everything I deserve to be reek as
depressing and might I add boring as
this whole gray joyless story line is
for once I'm glad that this show kills
off characters quickly certainly we
don't have to put up with him for more
than a couple more episodes right and we
eat first and hit hard and leave a feast
for the crows roll pages so have you
decided yet whether I'm worthy of your
service have you decided yet whether
you're going to have me killed
as much maligned as this season maybe
the teaming up of these two is a stroke
of genius
it's the Dustin and Steve of Game of
Thrones with that being said this
conversation goes on for another four
minutes and nothing as accomplished or
said that we don't already know which is
a little - Walking Dead for my taste at
least there are no giant confusing melee
zombie attacks in this year if not me
for so long and now I'm just gonna say
it how the [ __ ] does she have curls like
this in the front and not the back
curling irons aren't a thing in Game of
Thrones if I want
I'll get myself a proper fool TB sends
critics and fans a single person who
shares your blood is the life to support
you or ride your dragon if you know what
I mean let me fight for her and I belong
to you I don't know what your long game
is here but he's become the most
pathetic character on this show and Sam
is still alive that's T confess or just
move your head forward a half inch the
spoon is right there yeah you deceived
God someone is working out there
Catholic school upbringing in this
writing if she's desperate enough to
suck the water off the stones why is she
letting it drip back out of her mouth
without swallowing it not once but twice
does it hurt no because when the skin
cracks open like a dragon egg it feels
like a zippity-doo-dah candy dream I've
seen the army of the Dead well I haven't
missed a but used to good in it how Zack
Snyder he is try not to worry Olli I've
been worrying about John for years
doesn't he mean months or maybe a year
the only thing more confusing than the
geography on this show is the timetable
Sam rescued Gilly maybe a few months
after meeting John and her baby still
looks about the same age so how has it
been years wasn't that open sea just a
moment ago CG guys come on
just copy paste water is it that hard
you just know John's now does that make
me a fool it absolutely does but to be
fair with the kind of moves seriously
Stannis and Bolton have been making
lately John is maybe only the fourth
biggest idiot on the ship though the
bones that's funny
Lord of bones is what my college
girlfriend used to call my college
roommate I didn't even realize game with
roses around back there well we the
secret to surviving the frigid north is
no roof we've been doing it wrong this
whole time there are old stories about
ice spiders big as hounds oh well there
are are there well no that does it if
the show doesn't pony up with some giant
ice spiders soon it's a complete and
utter failure on every level do my
bidding Joe I put an arrow through his
ha oh come on this is enemy territory
why would you shade the truth in the
opposite direction
you gave them a merciful death when
others wanted to torture him I know
torment is going to spell that out here
soon but considering how quickly death
can come I say maybe you leave with that
this is do it also I killed the lower
bones a minute ago that's cool I'm right
behind you I promise this was like the
Game of Thrones version of the I'll be
right back and the one last Jon cliches
all smash together yeah just like that
this random ice queen is tact or certain
death Game of Thrones fallen Kingdom
there's almost 20 minutes left in this
episode and it's about to get real and
damn it if this show doesn't completely
own my ass right
[Applause]
this section of the fight scene is
inspired by a Black Friday sales event
at Walmart considering the size of the
building pounds the giant ever standing
up inside in the first place bad guy has
opportunity to stab hero in the chest
but ops for blunt end of the weapon
instead cliche and even though this army
has shown to be unrelenting these ice
ice babies are gonna hold for effect for
about 10 seconds because TV show has a
TV show also I get my car CEA's freaked
out here but to be fair they could just
be looking for a seven-person for a
friendly game of stickball that's good
luck to you guys we've unfortunately he
got Mets tickets so does any show finish
each episode as strong as Thrones I
swear to drogon this show sticks the
landing like it's Kerri Strug circa 1996
[Music]
the Sun doin matter to missus in confess
sometimes when I'm driving I have this
sudden impulse to turn the wheel quickly
head-on into the oncoming car why did
you come back we played a long game you
and I but now it's over
does it hurt I like to say something dab
for Paris hello how about that ride in